en swahili mahoua ça veut dire fleurs
chaque matin depuis 20 ans mame awa se
rend au marché aux poissons de dar es
salaam
[Musique]
mes qualités je n'ai pas vraiment choisi
ce métier mais la vie est difficile et
il fallait bien faire quelque chose pour
vivre comme je ne suis pas allé à
l'école je me suis retrouvé à travailler
ici pour nourrir ma famille et je suis
devenue vendeuse de poisson
comme si toute la ville s'étaient donné
rendez vous au marché de magot goni
ferry
[Musique]
m
depuis l'aube les boutres de pêche se
succèdent sur le banc de sable qui fait
office de quais de déchargement
toute la journée des tonnes de poissons
passe des calots table de vente dans une
joyeuse cacophonie
mais pour le plus grand bonheur des
ténors du marché a dit hussein n'est
certes pas le plus discret de cette
caste des crieurs les il est sans doute
l'un des meilleurs de la place j'ai
commencé comme pêcheur mais j'ai vite
compris que c'était un métier très dur
et très fatigant pêcher en mer et je
veux vendre mon poisson ici et je me
suis rendu compte que j'étais surtout
bon pour ça je vendais 200 par 6 200 par
là et je m'améliore à chaque jour on est
un peu comme des chanteurs travaillent
d'autres voies pour que les gens aiment
notre musique mais le caruso des étals
c'est heureusement donner de la voix
dans plusieurs registres
en fait j'étais sans voix différente
la première fait comme ça la deuxième
c'est pour dire du shilling et à la
maison je prends ma voix toute douce
bonjour ma chérie comment savoir comment
a été ajournée
ça s'est bien passé
bien sûr je dois parler à haute voix
pour que mes clients m'ont compte bien
et qu'ils aient envie d'acheter mes
poissons
le meilleur public de cet opéra bouffe
quotidien ce sont les centaines de mama
de dar es salaam cliente fidèle et
exigeante qui du matin au soir
get la bonne affaire
mame awa elle achète toujours à la même
table sur de trouver au plus bas prix le
poisson qu'elle recherche sur cette
table c'est du poisson pas trop cher
pour nous les mama que nous pour à la
cuisiner et vendre ensuite sur d'autres
tables ce sont des hommes qui achètent
du poisson de meilleure qualité pour le
vendre frais à des prix beaucoup plus
élevés que les nôtres c'est que mame awa
s'est spécialisé dans un commerce sur
lequel elle et ses collègues règne sans
partage
celui du poisson fruits une version
africaine du fish and chips dont
raffolent les habitants de dar es salaam
et qui fournit du travail à une armée de
petites mains payés à la tâche sous la
halle réservé aux nettoyeurs ramadân se
charge de préparer les derniers achats
de mahwah pour une poignée de shillings
je frotte les poissons avec du sable
pour les étayer
et je les vides très bien payé mais vous
savez en tant qu'ami beaucoup de
problèmes pour trouver de quoi vivre et
c'est pour ça que je fais ça oui
hadj lui a trouvé la combine pour ne pas
trop se salir les mains et chevaucher
son bolide la tête haute
c'est le même vélo que j'utilise pour
venir de chez moi et faire tourner ma
pierre
grâce à ce système et je ne pense plus à
voler comme avant la vie reste dur mais
au moins j'ai la gagne honnêtement
quant à monsieur kofia l'homme au
chapeau il fait partie des dizaines de
laveurs de poissons qui barbotent sur la
plage et son pays au panier percé
m
c'est dire s'il n'a pas le temps de
répondre aux questions des moussons go
c'est drôle de blancs venus d'ailleurs
je me dépêche parce que j'ai des clients
qui sont passés il ya tellement de monde
qui compte sur mon travail
si je m'arrête je pouvais passer à tous
mes clients et je risque d'en perdre au
passage les proto panier et on y va
et vous arrêtez de nous déranger avec
houllier vous les gars amener mon
espagne et s'entraîner
oui
c'est l'économique
ces poissons enfin nettoyer et l'avait
mame awa peut aborder maintenant
l'épreuve finale de son parcours du
combattant des poissonneries
direction la cuisine c'est marmite du
diable et ses 40 degrés la langue
c'est vraiment mieux qu'avant parce que
la cuisine était à ciel ouvert
maintenant il y a un toit au-dessus des
fourneaux et on attend à l'abri du
soleil
une poignée de sel un bon quart d'heure
dans l'huile de palme la recette est
simple le client rarement exigeant
[Musique]
alors oui mais voilà mes poissons sont
prêts à nous les mamans on ne vend pas
le poisson frais comme d'autres ont le
vent pris nos clients l'achètent pour le
manger de suite
reste une petite demi-heure de dallas
dallas pour traverser la ville et vendre
sa friture
[Applaudissements]
l'occasion de répandre les bonnes odeurs
de poissons dans les rues de l'ancienne
cité coloniale allemande
mais le petit commerce des mama est
aujourd'hui menacé situé à l'entrée de
la baie de dar es salaam l'agonie ferry
est le seul marché aux poissons de la
ville et l'un de ses principaux poumons
économique livrée clé en main par les
japonais il y a deux ans il est
construit à l'emplacement de l'ancienne
halle aux poissons
c'est à dire au beau milieu du chenal
d'accès au port de commerce et la sphère
commence à faire quelques vagues
quand on les charge d'autres pêches nos
boutre tap les uns contre les autres ou
d'autres le quai à cause des vagues des
gros bateaux qui passent elles au caire
et puis mes yeux cet accident il ya dix
ans entre un gros et un petit bateau
c'était avec le victoria dans les années
90 neuf personnes sont mortes et ici on
se souvient tous de cette histoire
aucun accident depuis deux ans mais le
risque est là en permanence depuis sa
tour de contrôle bakst halo wars and i
est aux premières loges pour observer le
périlleux chassé croisé qui se déroule à
chaque entrée et sortie d'un navire
chargé du contrôle du chenal il imagine
parfois le pire
il y à beaucoup d'autres qui viennent
décharger en même temps pendant qu'un
gros bateaux à rentrer au port
il est quand même effet le même messi
beaucoup mais si donc ça m'a rappelé il
suffit que son moteur tombe en panne et
il ne pourra rien faire pour s'arrêter à
tout le monde et éviter l'accident avec
tous ces gens qui travaillent au pied du
marché
le port de dar es salaam et le second
d'afrique de l'est et son directeur
supportent de plus en plus mal cette
entrave à son trafic maritime
surtout depuis un certain mardi noir la
construction du marché
il ya eu le 11 septembre et toutes ses
conséquences depuis la sécurité des
navires est devenu nettement plus
importante que la survie d'un marché aux
poissons
et comme il n'est bien sûr pas question
de déplacer le port on a décidé de
séparer les petits bateaux des grands et
pour qu'ils n'empruntent plus le même
jeune âge
nous allons transférer le déchargement
des goûts très moussa saïb et où l'on va
devoir aménager une nouvelle zone de
déchargement pour les pêcheurs ce
déménagement inévitable risque fort de
bousculer l'incroyable l'organisation du
marché aux poissons
nawa enfin arrivés à destination ne peut
que s'inquiéter de ce qu'elle considère
comme la mort annoncée du petit commerce
des mama dacquois déménager une partie
du marché amm sasany b ça va changer
beaucoup de choses pour nous le marché
actuel est très loin d'ici
les gens n'ont pas le courage de prendre
le bus pour aller chercher du poisson
mais sasany c'est juste à côté
les gens pourront aller acheter
facilement du poisson pour me schilling
et ça va tenter monde et nous comment on
va faire pour survivre aux alliés
parfois
au pied du marché deux magots goni ferry
le ballet des navires de commerce
poursuit imperturbablement et les
monstres d'acier reprennent la mer sans
se douter qu'ils emportent dans leur
sillage les espoirs d'une vendeuse de
poisson au doux nom de fleur